يعني سلمى نحن مضطرون للاحتماء والبقاء
على الارض لانك كما تسمعين في الخلفيه
اصوات اطلاق نار ويبدو اننا امام اشتباك
مسلح يدور تحديدا في منطقه دوار السينما
حيث نتواجد وراينا
يعني هل تسمعين نعم
نسمع نعم يعني اصوات كثيفه لاطلاق النار
وابل من الرصاص لا نستطيع التحديد ما الذي
يحدث فعليا سوى ان هناك بالفعل اشتباك
مسلح جاء ذلك وفق ايضا تحركات مستمره
لدوريات الاحتلال داخل جنين دون اتضاح
الموقف حتى هذه اللحظه قوات الاحتلال كانت
قد اقتحمت المدينه من حاجز الجلمه و فور
وصول الاليات العسكريه الى وسط مدينه جنين
اندلعت اشتباكات عنيفه وسط المدينه
والدوار الرئيسي كما ذكرت لك حيث نتواجد
واشتباكات مسلحه تدور في هذه الاثناء بين
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والمقاومين
الفلسطينيين ووفق مصادر مطلعه ان ما يجري
هو تبادل اطلاق ل النار يعني
تم ايضا احتلال الان يصلنا عدد من
البنايات السكنيه ومنازل
وتم نصب القناصه ووضعهم على اعلى هذه
البنايات اي بالطبع ايضا يصلنا الان تباعا
اي انه يتم ايضا
اقتحام نعم يتم حتى في هذه الاثناء اقتحام
مدينه طولكرم اذا نتحدث الان ان هناك
اقتحام اي يعني في ذات اللحظه ل وسط مدينه
جنين وسط مدينه طول كرم وايضا وسط مدينه
رام الله واحياء عده في المدينه وايضا في
مدينه البيره باحياء الطيره والبوع لكن
نحن نتواجد الان في وسط يعني المدينه
وواضح كم هو حجم هذه الاشتباكات المسلحه